j'ignore si on peut naître optimiste
mais je sais qu'on peut tomber dans la
marmite d'optimisme tout petit c'est ce
qui m'est arrivé j'ai mis du temps à le
comprendre
évidemment dans mon cas c'était pas
panoramix qui tout y est
mais ma mère
ma mère c'est quelqu'un qui a le bonheur
simple et cultive son jardin étaient 82
à metz en lorraine c'est l'année où je
devais choisir mon orientation scolaire
les gens profité pour parler à ma mère
de mon ennui maladif mon ennui
mais fabien l'optimisme de bonheur tout
ça c'est d'la tête
il suffit de lui décidé mais qu'est ce
que tu racontes avec quoi tu vires l'air
franchement si le bonheur d'optimisme on
décide c'est de la triche
c'est par un truc il faut être logique
quoi évidemment à force d'être logique
je suis devenu informaticien donc quinze
ans plus tard je suis dans un bureau
directeur informatique j'envisage de
faire un billet de devenir dirigeant
enfin vous voyez tout un panneau pis
quoi mon téléphone sonne
un lieutenant de gendarmerie monsieur
renard votre épouse vient d'avoir un
accident et vous pressez pas pour venir
tout est sous contrôle de temps
l'arrivée je suis veuf
dans les semaines et les mois qui
suivent évidemment je me sens au fond du
gouffre
mais je sais que je remonterai j'en
doute jamais une seconde
mon réflexe chevillée au coeur l'espoir
de lendemains qui chanteront en
permanence dur sans ça il ya des pensées
qui m'arrive tout seul comme ça
je refuse de survivre je veux vivre et
je veux vivre dans le bonheur commence à
la vie serait injuste navy ayeni justes
et injustes et juste la vie quoi et je
sens que si je lui fais confiance
allez offrir à des choses que je
voudrais même pas à lui demander
docteur
je serai optimiste moi qui me prenait
pour un râleur un espèce de d'éternels
insatisfaits et voyons fait bien ça n'a
rien à voir c'est pas incompatibles j'ai
français n'est ce pas râler ça fait
partie de mon identité nationale et
aujourd'hui je me sens pleinement
heureux
je n'avais que j'avais fantasmer à
l'époque
à tous points de vue
et du coup je me suis fait une forte
conviction
à ce moment-là que j'ai toujours gardé
nous créons notre réalité
nous créons notre réalité parce que nous
devenons ce à quoi nous pensons le plus
souvent
évidemment ça fonctionne pour le positif
comme pour les négatifs du coup les
optimistes ont davantage tendance à
réussir ce qu'ils entreprennent
et ce qui est chouette la bonne nouvelle
c'est que devenir optimiste ça peut
s'apprendre c'est ce que montre la
psychologie positive et vous en doutez
ce soir ici c'est exactement ce que je
m'apprête à ne pas développer avec vous
mais vous trouverez des tonnes de
conférences ted et de livres sur le
sujet parce que moi que je vais
continuer à faire c'est à vous raconter
un petit peu de mon histoire
ensuite je suis devenu un acteur
humaniste auprès des entreprises
et aussi un écrivain engagé de plus en
plus engagée autour d'une conviction
nous ne sommes plus en crise
nous sommes en mutation nous devons
organiser la transition
inventer une société plus juste plus
respectueuse de notre mère à tous
plus propices à créer du bonheur
merci moi je me disais qu'il y avait une
personne qui était d'accord en fait on
assiste c'est cool génial merci on est
au bon endroit
vous avez raison ça fait un petit peu
écolos 1
mais comme on se refait pas vous avez
devant vous un écho l'optimiste
pourquoi y ait deux parce que à mon goût
c'est comme les frites et celle ensemble
c'est assez magique mais chacun des
éléments épisode c'est moyen-moyen
prenez l'écologie tout seul depuis des
décennies on envoyait des messages
on a écrit des essais on a tourné des
documentaires alarmiste
c'était indispensable dans un premier
temps
mais au bout d'un certain temps
ça plombe sa culpabiliser et du coup ça
éloigne les autres côté d'optimisme seul
il ya une espèce de d'optimisme tendance
en ce moment qui me gonflent
prodigieusement ya pas longtemps j'ai
été invité à une de ces grands-messes
fait au milieu d'un parterre de
dirigeants et de grands communicants et
je me suis emparé du micro pour crier
mon agacement
iter était optimiste jusqu'à la dernière
minute de sa vie il pensait que
l'allemagne pourrait gagner la guerre
fallait y croire quand même dans son
bunker
la question c'est que pour moi
l'optimisme ne devrait pas être une fin
la question c'est que certes il que sert
l'optimisme
d'ailleurs j'ai continué en disant les
actionnaires des sociétés mortifère
c'est qu'ils foutent en l'air la planète
et aussi des gens qui sont dessus ils
sont probablement optimiste ça roule
pour eux
bon ok
je vous entends penser j'y suis allé un
peu fort c'est ce qu'ils ont pensé aussi
démontré d'ailleurs mais j'exècre cette
récupération d optimisme par deux
systèmes des plus grandes marques de la
consommation et des politiques unis dans
une même supplique
sainte croissance prié pour nous
donnez nous aujourd'hui notre
consommation de ce jour et surtout fait
que rien ne change
alors que moi ce qui me porte
ce en quoi je crois c'est l'optimisme
applique à une vision par exemple
d'écologie c'est ça qui peut donner la
deuxième vague de l'écologie l'écologie
qui montre des possibles des
alternatives
qui dresse les contours d'une vie à la
fois belle désirable
mais surtout soutenable
alors évidemment la transition de
société c'est plutôt un portable mais on
a réussi rassis on y croit vraiment
ce que la chenille ressent probablement
comme la la fin du monde
l'homme appelle la naissance d'un
papillon
alors bien sûr c'est pas les puissants
qui vont porter le changement ça c'est
pas possible ce qui n'ont aucun intérêt
c'est pas non plus les politiciens parce
qu'ils ont perdu leur pouvoir sur la
marche du monde
nous avons de pouvoir de changer les
choses mais pour ça il faut qu'on
retrouve deux sens objectif
dans l'après-guerre
une vision collective s'est imposée
autour d'une phrase plus jamais ça
c'était une vision collective européenne
et en même temps dans tous les pays une
vision nationale s'impose est de fait la
reconstruction
aujourd'hui en 2014 calé l'idéal est que
nous partageons
difficile de répondre
est-ce qu'il n'est pas tendre se poser
la question pour retrouver une vision
pour retrouver tout simplement de sens
et réenchanter la société elle en a bien
besoin
pour ça je voudrais vous proposer deux
pistes sur les rangs lentement la
première c'est autour de la citoyenneté
avant de m'intéresser à ce sujet là
j'étais persuadé de vivre dans une
démocratie abouti sur prétexte que nous
sommes libres et que nous élisons donc
non choisies sont ce qu'ils sont censés
nous représenter
mais la démocratie c'est bien plus que
ça c'est de pouvoir par le peuple pour
le peuple
pourtant toutes les décisions se
prennent sans nous
quand avons nous une occasion d'être
acteur
la dictature c'est ferme ta gueule et la
démocratie c'est cause toujours disait
ce grand philosophe français moyen
il est vital que ça change et de gemin
dont je vais vous dire quelques mots
c'est peut-être ce maillon manquant de
la démocratie
imaginez à côté de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat qui sont composés à quasi à
100% de politiciens professionnels
imaginer mille citoyens volontaires et à
la fois tiré au sort mille personnes
1000 français comme vous et moi des
jeunes des vieux tous les métiers et
toutes les origines des chômeurs des
personnes d'origine étrangère qui sont
qui seront interrogés consulter pour
toutes les décisions importantes
et il serait légitime à de fer est très
compétent parce qu'il serait on leur
donnerait l'information pour bien
informer les gens sont des citoyens mal
informés ils deviennent des sujets
merci enfin c'est pas de moi la phrase
mais merci quand même important il
délibère ray plutôt que de se confronter
le premier gemin français est
actuellement en projet commencera par
une journée nationale de consultation
des français sur leurs enjeux majeurs il
utilisera d'une manière plutôt innovante
et très constructive la télévision les
réseaux sociaux et aussi les autres
médias
si tout se passe bien ça sera fin 2015
vous bien l'année prochaine mais c'est
pas gagné
du coup de génie france a besoin de
toutes les bonnes volontés
deuxième piste pour réenchanter la
société l'art est ce que vous savez que
dans l'après guerre les américains avec
le plan marshall nous ont injecté
massivement leurs cultures à travers le
cinéma en particulier dans des beaux
films
ils nous ont envoyé notre modèle de
société
en partie composées d'une consommation
outrancière et on a adopté le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que ce modèle n'est
pas durable
on sait bien
bah si on a remplacé par une vision
à la fois belle et soutenable parce
qu'en plus on peut utiliser exactement
les mêmes techniques
ils s'y sont pas pris de manière
rationnelle mais émotionnel tempe a fait
des tournées de conférences en disant on
va vous expliquer aux européens
pourquoi la consommation c'est vachement
bien non c'est pas ça quand on veut
mettre l'humain en mouvement ça son
coeur qu'il faut par d
davantage qu'à sa tête
c'est pour ça que je rêve
les artistes s'engagent de plus en plus
comme dit un de mes amis il est temps
d'inventer une nouvelle mythologie
c'est pour ça que moi personnellement
dans mes écrits utilise la forme
romanesque
je passe par l'émotionnel
et même dans les entreprises c'est ce
que je fais et vous savez quoi ça marche
mais imaginez ya neuf ans je commençais
les premières lignes de mon premier
roman
personne n'en a voulu 25 éditeurs
personnage
aujourd'hui
mon dernier texte qui s'appelle des
semences et des hommes et du sur scène
la première d'ailleurs ça a été à la
rochelle
jeanne attachement réflectif du coup et
je suis un tout jeune auteur de bandes
dessinées pour glénat et seigneurs de la
terre une saga qui est très prometteuse
c'était vraiment une utopie pour moi de
devenir un vrai écrivain havrais auteur
mais comme je n'ai pas lâché
elle est devenue réalité
et vous quels sont vos utopia
quels sont vos rêves ceux qui sont bons
pour vous
et au delà de vous qui vous dépasse
si jamais vous les avez oublié repenser
ici on a tous eu des rêves et des
utopies
pourquoi attendre davantage
et s'il a tout de suite vous décidiez de
vous mettre en marche dès demain matin
peut-être dès ce soir ensemble on peut
tout réussir
j'en suis complètement convaincu
vous êtes les étoiles nous sommes
l'univers
vous êtes un grain de sable nous sommes
le désert vous êtes mille pages et moi
je suis la pum
et ça sonne bien
ça serait pas du neuf
et james g james s'est pas trop fait
tu aimes tu pourrais jouer quelques
notes de 16
poggia me tiens tiens j'ai pas dit du
jazz
j'ai dit du zaz vous êtes des étoiles
nous sommes univers vous êtes un grain
de sable sont mieux désert vous êtes
mines page et moi je suis la plume ooo
ooo wow oh oh oh